uh we have this tweet from the recount a
moment ago I was talking about how
Tucker Carlson suggested we may be under
attack we've got unidentified flying
objects being shot down maybe that's a
distraction we've got infrastructure
being attacked we've got train
derailments we've got chickens being
cold egg shortages or avian floor
whatever seems like our infrastructure
is being hit pretty hard especially with
the Chinese spy balloon flying over I
mean the first thing China would do is
subversive tactics to weaken our economy
and throw us off balance before making a
militaristic move which would require a
military response on our end we got this
tweet lock your doors tonight listen to
this this has been going on for a long
long time
at least
2017. and last week we were told 2019
um
that's what I took away from it today
thanks guys appreciate it lock your
doors tonight thank you okay he was
being asked about UFOs being shot down
and he says we're finding out it's been
going on for for a lot longer than we
realize lock your doors tonight now of
course the way we've we can frame this
is when asked about UFOs the senator
said lock your doors tonight as if to
imply what
what's he implying with this that is
implying that you should protect
yourself from being probed maybe but
like let's think about this
realistically he's not literally saying
aliens or anything like that we're
talking about unidentified flying
objects and Chinese spy balloons who's
to lock your doors that sounds like
there's some kind of sabotage going on
I don't know I mean he's the he's a a
poster Kenneth he's so funny he's
pretty hilarious he had the uh when the
commercial where he was like next time
telling like defund the police out kids
uh next time you get in trouble call
crackhead yeah like he is pretty severe
but with this I mean he saw her in in
the in the moment I I wonder is that
smirk on after he walks away I wonder if
it's uh that he thinks the general chaos
of balloons like it's not necessarily
that aliens are going to touch down or
whatever but that General instability is
coming and this will be the culmination
of all the chaos that's been happening
especially if you're from Louisiana
explosions and you know disasters lock
your doors because you know they're
coming do you have a plan for your
constituents as to what to do when the
aliens invade your District
I feel like that's some high level stuff
I'd be like most of most of my
preparation was around how are we going
to fix the roads not how are we going to
stop alien invasions yeah I don't think
I'll try I will do my best for the
people of mon County but I can't make
any promises regarding extraterrestrial
Invasion the the sad thing is that part
of me wants it to be aliens because it's
so bad it sounds like that I was
thinking that too maybe that's but then
like the aliens would just wipe us out
and take over Independence Day you know
yeah there was there were some losses
I'm not so I blew up the White House
there's some laws I'm not so I'm not so
like hoping that it's aliens but I there
is part of me that's like man I hope
it's something interesting yeah you know
it's gonna turn out to be just like the
Chinese military
that's what we thought it was well this
sucks
and then what I mean I I suppose the sad
thing is it's gonna turn out to be
something mundane like
Chinese military engaging in preemptive
surveillance as they prepare a military
action on Taiwan and then we're gonna be
like well that's boring
you know like it's funny I think that's
what they want for you to be like oh
just not that big a deal even though
that is kind of a huge deal I mean it'll
mean War it's just that that's what we
expect and that's boring you know going
like oh everybody expects there's gonna
be a war with China it's the city's trap
they want Taiwan we don't want to take
Taiwan a spy balloon flies over weird
things are flying over the country you
gotta lock your doors at night yeah yeah
we get it it's Russia or China world war
three is gonna start Have We Become that
cynical where we could actually get to
the point where world war three is is
start has actually started and people
are just like yeah we wanted to start
for the memes
that's what they these people cannot
wait for war to break out just so they
can get some likes right I mean maybe
maybe there's something to that maybe
maybe the the nihilism that is and this
might lead into I don't know when you
want to talk about that other story
about the uh the depression and stuff
but this might might lead into or be
from the the nihilism that seems to be
taking hold with with young people like
well I think it's a symptom of the
24-hour news cycle right you've got a
report on something so we've been
reporting on potential dangers in Taiwan
potential aggression for a long long
time it doesn't seem as dramatic as all
of a sudden there was a bomb dropped
right and fair enough but there are
other Generations that didn't have the
exposure to constant news through social
media fair enough but we we are we are
actively arming Ukraine and they're in a
hot war with a nuclear arm but it's
easier for your peer it's easier to
start tuning it out when you hear about
it non-stop I mean how many outlets out
there are constantly updating you about
how what's going on on Ukraine it's not
that it's not serious but you become
sort of numb to it I don't think it's
nihilism so much as just overexposure
maybe you're like dopamine drained and
you're also your adrenals are just like
shot it all starts to sound the same
right you know something bad is going on
you know this but nothing is so severe
that it it means there's an official War
it means whatever that's that's reality
you know how long the American
Revolution took 20 years you were
talking about 20 years the revolutionary
period they called in I suppose you can
argue that the official War wasn't until
you know a declaration or something like
that but you you had Conflict for years
I mean the separation of the Boston
Massacre and the Boston Tea Party was
years so I mean think about it it's been
three years since it's it's 2023.
imagine three years ago was the
beginning of the pandemic it seems like
a really long time to us yeah now think
about Donald Trump getting elected
that's seven years wow well not seven
but six just a little bit over six years
Trump getting getting elected for his
first term
it feels like forever ago sort of but it
also kind of feels like the blink of an
eye but when they write about this I I
often talk about this one in the future
when they write about this period world
war three second Civil War pandemic
whatever you want to call it whatever it
may be because we can't see the future
there's gonna be a huge chunk of time
and for all we know they say it all
started on August 17 2011 when activists
came to New York City to forget to begin
preparations for Occupy Wall Street they
may say that was the moment it began but
even that moment had a precursor you had
the WTO protests in in Seattle the
battle in Seattle in 99 but that was a
bit far away I mean that's we're talking
12 years maybe that preliminary meeting
for Occupy Wall Street is what kicked
off the culture wars which leads to
internal conflict in all of this and
it's all part of one big conflict period
fourth turning or whatever you want to
call it I find myself picturing the uh
history textbook I used in sixth grade
where certain terms were bolded and you
were supposed to learn them and they
were these key moments because you have
to be able to boil down history you know
into small enough portions where you can
start remembering it before you can add
in all the details and at one point like
I I found myself checking on us and
being like Oh so is this the bolded term
that a different generation will get
they'll have to remember this date in
particular it's it's impossible to tell
from where we stand right now we were
pretty sure they'll remember when Russia
invaded Ukraine this time around but I
don't know that anyone can tell you when
Russia went into Crimea the last time I
mean they might write that World War 43
started in 2014 yeah with the uh the
Euro by Dan protest oh right beginning
well arguably end of 2013 with your my
dad protest and which which uh carried
on to 2014 or right the invasion of
Crimea the annexation of Crimea but then
you have to wonder what precipitated
Ukraine it may say the Syrian Civil War
it may be the Arab Spring yeah the Arab
Spring period of of uh instability
destabilization of these countries
created openings for Terror
organizations and conflict which are to
spread then you get the conflict in
Syria then the U.S moves in et cetera et
cetera and this this whole thing breaks
out but I mean if you think about it
nobody talks about World War One in the
sense of well it didn't really start
with the assassination of Archduke Franz
Ferdinand it's actually the reason he
was assassinated was because no
everybody says that started it it was
the assassination but clearly there was
a reason dude got assassinated a ton of
build up a ton of build up yeah I think
the thing is
yo we're in the forest right we can't
see it you leave the forest and you can
be like wow that's a huge Forest nah
we're right in the middle of it that's
one thing when I like I keep talking
about like a cultural revolution in the
U.S and I think that's the reason why
people don't realize that it's going on
is because it's actively happening and
and if they could take a step back they
would see the similarities between like
you know the BLM protest and the Red
Guard in in the in China in the 60s it's
like watching a time lapse
when you actually watch the time lapse
of the flower growing and like the guy
pushes the seed so they'll put like a
little piece of glass and the dirt up
against it in the pot you see the finger
push the seated in pour water and then
it time lapses the whole thing growing
if you did that yourself
you would not see the growth ever yeah
you'd walk up one day and it would look
a little bit bigger but you wouldn't
really think twice the next day be like
oh look there's a little bit more the
next day it's it's blossoming you're
like oh wow but you don't see it all
happen at once so it's not a shocking
moment to you so how far removed how far
out of the forest do we have to be
before we can watch the entire time
lapse and say you know what this starts
to make sense I can see where I could
see how it started so basically you're
saying once the war is over we will look
back and be like oh yeah yeah the war's
over
I mean unless it goes to like a real
significant Hot War where like you know
it's act where it's undeniably a hot
warp but that's otherwise yeah I think
we're gonna see in Modern Warfare it is
not going to be you boats landing on
shores or whatever or missiles flying
through the air it's going to be like
chemical trains exploding and spewing
toxic chemicals over a 200 mile radius
it's going to be people shooting up
power substations it's going to be
millions of chickens all of a sudden
getting sick you know why someone super
chatted this us to us yesterday that the
reason Buffalo nearly went extinct is
because the Pioneers were killing them
intentionally to destroy the Native
Americans food supply so they could win
the war the wars against them so if our
food is being corrupted disrupted or
destroyed our livestock for instance
that could be Warfare yeah and we may
just be too stupid and like oh look at
that our chickens die that's so strange
there's war as we know is going to take
place on multiple fronts I've always
seen the the comparisons of Chinese Tick
Tock versus our Tick Tock where our Tick
Tock puts the dumbest things imaginable
on the front and kids get addicted to it
because that's what kids do but Chinese
Tick Tock it's all engineering academic
Innovation these kids doing crazy crazy
things that they can aspire to and
there's this massive destabilization
effort of our culture of the of young
people which is you know that's the
stock of Tomorrow yep so it's it's going
to take place so if you come combine
that with attacks on the food attacks on
the power grid attacks on the water it's
really we'll we'll destroy ourselves
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time